ca for me
bud
s so you C down this is where he can do
that cuz he's on the road just calm me
down for a second chill
chill stop
it stop it sit
up outrage in Central Florida after body
cam footage shows police handcuffing a
99-year-old student for 13 minutes
inside of his own
classroom the incident happened on
February 2nd of this year at an
elementary school in Ido Florida
according to the incident report two OVO
police officers were called to stenstrom
elementary school in response to an
unruly
child
no this is one of those situations man
just why I can't be an SRO here on
officer yes sh Mona's body cam you can
see the child throwing paper and books
that have been scattered across the
floor as staff members attempt to calm
the child down officer Manata then tries
to approach the student to try to
deescalate the situation but the officer
is met with fists and profanity from the
9-year-old don't oh you want to throw
stuff though
right you that's okay I get that a lot
it doesn't hurt my
feelings
staff members hold a blue punching bag
as the student continues to lash out
this time by kicking the teacher next
officer Scott Mosley responds to the
classroom while the student continues to
throw items across the room including a
wet floor sign moments later officer
Mosley handcuffs the student which
according to the incident report the
officer did so out of concern for others
in the
room don't touch me
until you C down this is where we're at
he can do that he's on the road just
calm you down for a second on officer
Mosley's body cam you can see the child
repeatedly kick the officers while they
attempt to restrain him once in cuffs
the student continues to scream
profanities stop it sit
up chill chill just
relax
need to
chill
you we can take the hand
shut no I'm not going to do that
according to the police report the
handcuffs were dangled Loosely around
the child's wrist but didn't allow the
hands out the child can be seen making
efforts to free himself from the Cuffs
officer Mosley is seen holding the
child's arm arms and wrote in the
incident report He adjusted the Cuffs
higher on the student arms so he could
not injure himself trying to get out
meanwhile officer monado is heard trying
to get the child to cool
down you're throwing things you're
putting
everyone you need to hear
it it's okay I get that a lot we're
trying to figure out why you're so
upset stop pulling stop stop
pulling stop picking out my
hand
relax if you relax we can talk to you
and you
can that's why you're not going
anywhere you know in another situation
you would be in very big trouble for
hitting a police officer shut up just
letting you know the older you get it's
going to be very harder for you to be
making these
behaviors you're doing really good well
officer tenant she gives you stickers
she sees she asks you how your day day
is and then this is how you treat us
yeah
you're you can relax we can take the
Cuffs off but you're literally
endangering everybody here by hitting
everybody and they don't come to work to
get beat
up they come to work to keep you safe
and teach you you that's fine a few
minutes later officer makata continues
to encourage the student to calm down so
he can be let go of the Cuffs you don't
care but you can go to jail for things
like that and I don't want to see you go
to jail for things like that okay
you can get you can get in trouble for
hitting staff
too okay I've done it since PR that's
not nice why do you do those
things because teachers
are but why they're only trying to teach
you okay but we want to get you off
those cuffs so you're trying to get Off
the Cuffs we can easily open them if you
just comply and talk to everybody to see
what's going on with you while you're
having a rough morning you're trying
really hard to take those cuffs off and
we want to take it off trust me we just
want to make sure everybody's
safe so can you talk to us next the
teacher is seen calmly speaking to the
student which seemingly calms him down
prompting officer Mosley to release the
student from the
handcuffs thanks
bud good job
buddy police say shortly after that they
were able to get the student to go to
the the guidance counselor's office the
child's parents are now suing the city
and the police department according to
local reports the parents of the student
filed the lawsuit at the end of
September against the two officers
involved in the incident citing the
entire thing caused extreme harm and
aggravated the child's existing
behavioral condition the lawyer for the
family who filed the lawsuit also
released a statement to local media
Outlets stating 9-year-old children
should not be handcuffed by police
officers at school and the City of OVO
failed to reach out to the family to
make any effort to address the
unfortunate situation reporting for long
crime Network I'm Elizabeth Milner